kyra is the medic she keeps the team
alive the healing grenade launcher
creates radial blasts of healing energy
the acceleration field accelerates caira
and those around her to blistering
speeds
the napalm grenade launcher deals fire
damage to the enemy
don't forget to use the healing burst
how's the research coming kyra
nothing you want to hear
try me
well i certainly don't think we've seen
everything these creatures can do given
the forms and abilities we've seen so
far
i'd say it's likely they can adapt
anything necessary to beat us
okay you're right i didn't want to hear
that told you
all right jay party ladies and gentlemen
boys and girls hunters of all ages and
monsters of all stages this is db
sinclair with jay party we're bringing
you another match-up evolve here showing
some of the newer content we just
released on a new map as well jay party
orbital drill yeah absolutely we were
practicing that before the match orbital
ah very good word orbital orbital
orbital drill here with a another new
hunter j party yeah look at that kyra
here the new medic and god i love this
medic the grenade barrage all of her
forms come in the way of giant
explosives here right now you look at
the incendiary grenade her offensive
weapon and boy is it effective it's
gonna light a large area on fire and get
that damage over time going on the
monster as well as any wildlife yeah
it's pretty cool jay party she has one
gun it just switches the cartridges out
it basically rotates and she goes from
napalm grenade to the healing grenade
she can actually shoot herself and her
teammates with that healing grenade heal
them up she also has the class ability
heel burst as
we've seen with val and lazarus and then
finally that acceleration field that you
mentioned before let's get your whole
team moving in the groove in on their
way to hunting the monster yeah that is
just so effective sometimes people under
utilize the speed perk in this game and
being able to give it to your entire
team at the same time in random bursts
is just so helpful there as you saw
shooting some of those healing grenades
it's super easy to switch back and forth
oh but a bouncer monster where's the
team here help your medic get him off
there nicely done by the monster to
pounce the medic mid air yeah absolutely
a great play there and he gets the
damage he needs the team was just not
ready to respond and you got to watch
out for that and evolve i love it as
part of the atom flow people get so
stuck on supporting your teammates using
those to help items you forget that you
need to keep a weapon on hand there and
look for those pounce attacks down goes
support with the big slam pajama to the
ground in the paw of goliath luckily
enough though support dragged goliath
away from the rest of the team they are
finally getting the medic up
disorganization
is the key to a disastrous start for the
hunters but they seem to have recovered
here jay party and that was such a good
play there gave the monster to time to
breathe even with that arena up he's
gonna get out fine now with a new
cooldown to wait for even though he's
only got two bars left he's got some
safety here it's gonna give him the time
to hopefully get this evolved and get to
stage two and boy does he needed that
health bar just so low at this point
goliath on the run taking a nice little
acid bath there jay party that is an
acid pool uh on this map that you will
find sort of around the edges and in
towards the middle of the map
which will damage both the hunters and
the monster if they decide to swim or
walk through there yeah gotta watch out
for all those environmental hazards as
we've seen it just take down whole teams
by itself there as a bunch of reavers
are picking on our medic here lucky for
kyra she's got strong aoe clearance and
that's super unique to her on the medic
field there not a lot of medics have
that good aoe clear it's one of the
strengths of kyrah as well as the
ability to heal heal herself with her
healing grenades that's another one of
the major perks of being kairez we're
seeing that speed perk here just allow
the hunters to cruise across this map
yeah nicely done another thing it does
for you jay party it allows you to run
on the ground when you run on the ground
your jet pack is constantly filling back
up with fuel and it's ready so when you
have that acceleration burst going
you're able to fly towards your target
and then when you need to use your jet
pack it's always on the ready nicely
done by kyra here oh except uh poor
timing from the trapper on the dome
trapped everybody but the monster jay
party that was rough slowing the hunters
down by a couple seconds there lucky for
them they still have tracking on this
monster that's so important for them to
get true sight of the monster it allows
you to really cut him off and allows you
to predict his movement which is so
important as a hunter yeah nicely done
with the dust tagging let's see if the
trapper can get up there and get some
stasis grenades on them also using that
uh
tracking dart gun to track the monster
that way as well if you double up on
those and you have them outlined in the
yellow and you have the tracking darts
in them as well
that monster is going to have a hard
time ditching you but right now they
don't seem to be on the same page with
that and the monster is free to move
around big rock throw misses though yeah
thinking of those grenades there wants
to just slow the monster down as you can
see there just getting to a slow crawl
as the monster has nowhere to really run
here he needs to escape from this area
as that armor is gone and he's taking
direct damage he was healthier yeah this
is actually great work finally from the
hunters you see the stasis grenade
slowing the monster down he was even in
a pit of acid at one point there so he's
taking acid he's taking constant damage
there's the uh damage amplifier from
support there on the monster allowing
the entire team to do extra damage and
now the monster under half health he
will see if the hunters can catch up to
him this is such a big moment for them
if they can just catch him one more time
before he evolves they're guaranteed a
win here but let's see if they can do it
as this goliath is playing smart here
getting a little bit of food but he
needs to stay on the move it needs to
keep building that armor and just stay
out of the fight he finally does get a
little bit of armor as you see some of
those napalm grenades flying above his
head nicely done by kyra before she went
down back there medic was down though
now on two strikes let's see how the
team comes back from this and there's
kyra keeping everyone at full health she
does such a good job of this that aoe
healing is so powerful for keeping your
team in the fights i absolutely love it
the difficulty is it is a skill shot
heel and with val it's very easy to just
target that metagun and you don't have
to think a lot about it but with kyra
every shot counts those grenades are so
important and your teammates need that
aoe heal to be very efficient to keep
everyone fighting that's right jay party
the flip side to that though is that it
is an aoe burst so you can heal multiple
targets while val can only heal one at a
time it's a nice trade-off though as
plain as kyra and look at that they get
the monster tracked again this cabin
doing such a good job of using that dust
tag it's such a powerful tool someone
think it's the too larger trade-off to
lose that barrage but having sight of
the monster this easily is just so
important for any team
they got him right where they want him
now finally get him in the dome as the
trap are starting to do work you see the
damage amplifier from support there and
the medic though getting caught up as
she's trying to heal and napalm the
monster getting caught in the uh against
the wall there uh oh they are in the
pool of acid pushed back into there and
did he go down j party no he's getting
back finally the trapper yeah makes the
head of there neither they want to be in
that high damage area for too long as
it's gonna bring you down and oh there
goes the trapper and with that goes the
arena the monster now able to fight at
his leisure and leave when things look
bad
got the team
right where he wants him or does he j
party he's in the pool of acid he's got
the stasis grenade on him he's running
through mines the monster having a tough
time here down under three bars of hell
yeah pushing the hunters into the water
though such a good strategy but down to
the two and a half bars here it's just
not looking good on this fight he needs
to really focus these last two hunters
if he wants to win this one yeah this is
a good fight for the hunters but assault
though just hanging out in the pool of
acid he goes down as well we see strikes
all over this hunter team and the
monster taking a temporary second of a
freeze there to eat the rest of that
meat get his evolved meter full and get
a little bit of armor in this fight
we'll see if he stays or if he runs away
here as the hunters are looking pretty
banged up in this fight he's
doing great work on him but they're
doing some pretty good work as well
staying together as a team here trying
to get that damage amp on him
medic down
trapper down
this is that leap
still able to interrupt that revive and
that's so important because he missed
that leap smash that would have been the
knockback he needed lucky for him he
gets that last second there and he's
able to disrupt it and try to kill a
hunter unfortunately they don't get the
kill and he's back up and in this fight
yeah back up and on the run two strikes
there or excuse me two bars of health
for the monster two strikes on almost
every hunter though j party we've got
support assault and the trapper in the
game medic is dead waiting for the drop
ship so we're looking at a beer using
that new tracking gun and i love this
gun it has a pretty cool unique ability
you can shoot it into the wildlife and
that's going to not only mark the
wildlife but if the monster ever eats
anything marked he'll be marked as he's
eating that tracking dart such a cool
ability allows you to keep tabs on a lot
of areas of the map mega mouth gets hold
of assault there they finally shoot the
mega mouth and assault gets out but look
how low on a healthy is without the
medic in the game yeah this is such a
rough situation of being lucky for them
that drops your timer just at zero and
kyra is coming back into this map as
assault needs to be so careful here just
coming next to a fly might kill him as
just breathing on him is going to knock
him over he looks like he's just running
back to the drop ship to say hey kyra
please heal me as soon as you get back
in in fact the entire team is there at
the landing zone waiting for her to drop
in here she comes
oh and she uh she drops past the team
there let's see if she can get a heel
burst on them and then use that gun to
top off the rest of the hunters assault
get up there get some heels
just desperate to get these heels off
and i don't blame him it's so important
there he doesn't have a second downed
penalty and he doesn't want one he needs
to get his health topped off and finally
they're getting there this team back on
the move here they finally topped off
their health bars and look at that that
movement speed perk allowing them to
just cruise across the map
and nicely done to use that acceleration
field on the entire team
as kyra you normally want to stand
towards the back of the group like she's
doing right now this is going to allow
you to catch up to the team and
actually push them forward with that
acceleration field it also allows you to
heal the entire group with that healing
grenade gun uh from behind
yeah we'll see that with the monster at
stage three that alternate win condition
the power relay does open up ooh but to
get eyes on him before he gets there and
god this monster's health has just
gotten so much higher than their last
encounter here up to half his health
with full armor this is gonna be a hard
fight for the hunters trapper gets
caught out trapper on two strikes this
could be it for him unless he's healed
by the medic nicely done by the medic to
drop those heels this is a great perch
for the medic dion and jay pardon you
can see the assault went up there laid
down a mine to keep the medics safe and
then went down below and laid some mines
down there and that's such an important
utility to use here you might not be
seeing it but that cabbage damage bonus
is being applied to the monster if he
ever hits a mine with that up it's going
to be huge sums of damage on the monster
the medic doing a great job of switching
between the healing grenades healing the
team and hitting with that uh damage
over time napalm grenade as well as
you're seeing here now
yeah she's doing a great job here the
monster realizes he's not gonna work
from his current position and he goes up
to clear the top of that ledge and
that's a definitely a key decision for
him here as that health bar starting to
dwindle starting to dwindle but nice use
of all of the utilities from support
there cloaking the teammates keeping
them safe up top the monster goes back
down into that little pit of doom down
there where he's trying not to work the
hunters have it locked down really well
yeah that rock missing the medic and
that's such an important thing here but
they have to watch out they're grouping
up a little too much down here and the
monster could get a double kill or a
triple here even a triple j party as the
trapper the only one keeping his
distance at the moment big rocks
here comes the follow-up leap smash nice
dodge by the trapper the monster though
down under a bar of health
health going down j party this could be
it this could be a hunter win and it is
indeed winner winner goliath for dinner
orbital drill j party what a match
we've seen now cabot we've seen abe and
the feature of the day kyra nicely done
by the kyber player there using all
those abilities jparty we'll see him
next time say goodbye to the world
thanks again for watching folks and
we'll catch you next time
you